secondo voi per vincere un concorso
pubblico oppure per fare un attacchi in
ospedale in tempi brevi oppure per avere
una licenza commerciale e occorre una
raccomandazione occorre conoscere
qualcuno in un ufficio
scommetto che tutti stiamo pensando di
si è però non siamo soli perché secondo
un sondaggio che ha fatto la commissione
europea
lo pensano nove italiani su dieci e la
cosa drammatica è che sette imprese su
dieci pensano che sia assolutamente
indispensabile
ecco ma allora c'è da chiedersi com'è
possibile cioè se tutti pensiamo così se
tutti abbiamo questa consapevolezza
com'è possibile che non gridiamo la
nostra rabbia la nostra indignazione
com'è possibile che non andiamo tutti a
denunciare tutti i favoritismi le
raccomandazioni le ingiustizie le
corruzioni perché la corruzione non è
soltanto quella penale quella dello
scambio di mazzette e anche lo scambio
di favori in tutta la comunità
internazionale è considerata così e come
è possibile che non corriamo tutti a
denunciare queste cose di cui ci
accorgiamo perché forse manca il senso
della corruzione come danno a tutti
della corruzione come danno a tutti noi
c'è un bel brano crowe sintetizza un
brano di camilleri uno scrittore
siciliano di erice parla della morale
del motorino si dice il motorino passa
con il rosso e nessuno dice niente il
motorino passa tra le macchine e nessuno
dice niente il motorino va contromano e
nessuno dice niente e anzi tutti diciamo
dalle macchine a quanto mi piacerebbe
essere su quel motorino
ecco è questa l'idea della mancata
percezione del danno a tutti lo dice
molto bene papà francesco
in un suo libro litscher corrotto
non si rende conto di essere corrotto
perché la corruzione lui dice non è un
atto ma è uno stato in cui ci si abitua
a vivere e manca davvero in questo senso
la percezione del danno eppure la
corruzione e dannosissima per la
comunità presidente mattarella il
presidente della repubblica da poco ha
detto alla corruzione è un furto di
democrazia
un furto di democrazia perché i
governanti non governano più pensando
all'interesse pubblico quello di tutti
noi
ma l'interesse soltanto di alcuni e poi
un danno all'economia
il presidente obama da pochissimo ha
riconosciuto che la corruzione il
maggiore ostacolo allo sviluppo
economico perché è una tassa indiretta
sulle imprese su tutte le imprese in
particolare su quelle che vogliono
entrare nei mercati quindi quelle dei
più giovani
ma non è soltanto un danno all'economia
e anche un rischio per la sicurezza
il presidente inglese cameron in
un'intervista all huffington post ha
detto che ha fatto notare come le
organizzazioni terroristiche
le organizzazioni estremistiche
reclutano i propri adepti dai paesi in
cui c'è maggiore pressione maggiore
corruzione e le gente che sfugge alla
corruzione all'oppressione così come
tutti i disperati
continua lui che attraversa nel
mediterraneo pervenire nelle nostre
terre cercando qui la speranza
sono tutte persone che corrono che
sfuggono dalla corruzione e
dall'oppressione e poi la corruzione
costituisce il maggiore ostacolo al
merito
ci sono delle statistiche veramente
inquietanti veramente interessanti una
statistica ci dice che le nazioni che
hanno il maggiore indice di percezione
della corruzione
cioè quelle in cui la gente ascoltata
dice che crede che il proprio paese sia
corrotto l'italia in questo senso è la
prima in europa
cioè la peggiore in europa ecco queste
nazioni sono quelle in cui abbiamo meno
investimenti scuola e in ricerca ma ce
n'è un'altra che forse ancora più
inquietante si è visto come questi paesi
in cui è maggiore l'indice di percezione
della corruzione sono i paesi in cui
maggiore è la fuga dei cervelli lo
sbilancio tra i laureati che escono e
laureati che entrano e allora che cosa
possiamo fare innanzitutto io credo che
sia importante dire che la corruzione
non è un problema di polizia e di
magistratura non è solo un problema di
polizia di magistratura perché i
cittadini tutti noi siamo le prime
sentinelle della legalità
ecco l'ocse che l'organizzazione
internazionale che si occupa di questa
materia si occupa anche di sviluppo
economico eco knox ci dice che occorre
un controllo sociale diffuso
occorre che tutti controlliamo i nostri
governanti e oggi è facile perché tutti
i paesi occidentali tra cui anche
l'italia hanno previsto l'obbligo per
tutte le amministrazioni di inserire
tutti i dati relativi alla loro attività
ai loro appalti a tutti i denari che
spendono in linea in open data quindi
tutti li possiamo controllare i dati
sono confrontabili per legge devono
essere confrontabili quindi siamo
chiamati a controllarli siamo chiamati
ad andare a verificarli
dobbiamo chiedere conto ai nostri
governanti del modo in cui loro spendono
i nostri soldi soldi delle tasse
poi c'è un secondo profilo importante
occorre una svolta culturale una svolta
culturale perché noi dobbiamo ribaltare
questa idea che c'è nell'immaginario
collettivo che i corrotti e corruttori
siano furbi siano furbi e vincenti ecco
questo è assolutamente fondamentale
isolare i corrotti e non ammettere che
ci sia un successo
grande o piccolo che non sia frutto di
impegno e del m
e poi c'è un terzo profilo forse il più
importante è quello di parlare ai
giovani e di raccontarle queste cose ai
giovani perché noi dobbiamo rafforzare
nei giovani la il senso
dell'appartenenza allo stato facendo
tornare di moda
l'impegno e ogni volta che ne abbiamo
parlato i giovani abbiamo avuto dai
giovani dei grandi risultati
penso agli angeli del fango ci
ricordiamo quei ragazzi che sparavano il
fango dopo le alluvioni prima a firenze
poi a genova
oppure pensate ai ragazzi che il 23
maggio a palermo affollano le strade a
migliaia a lottare a gridare contro la
mafia perché non vogliono la mafia
perché aveva ragione
caponnetto che voi ricordate era il
maestro dei nostri eroi civili falcone e
borsellino caponnetto diceva che la
mafia ha molta più paura della scuola e
della giustizia
grazie a tutti